És ez arról szól, hogy körülbelül 4,5
másodperccel hamarabb már megjelent a
bőrükön, illetve ezen a gépen kimutatta
a az a mérőeszköz, hogy már egy ilyen
izgalmi állapotba kerültek négy-öt
másodperccel azelőtt, hogy ők megnyomták
a gombot. És akkor azt mondták, vagy ezt
mutatták ki, hogy ez egy picit olyan egy
olyan, mint amikor nyitasz ki egy ahhoz
hasonlították, mint amikor egy csokit
nyit nyitasz ki jó lassan. Igen. És már
érzed magadba azt a megajándékozom
magam izgalmat, hogy végre az a csoki az
enyém lesz. és hogy ehhez hasonló
például csak versolvasás, a költészet
hallgatása és olvasása közben jön elő
bennünk. És azt is kimutatták, hogy
általában a a hallgatók és a költők a
akik olvasták, mindig a szakaszok vége
fele jött ez az izgalom, illetve az
egész versnek a vége fele.
[Zene]